KASLIN FIELDS: Today,
we'll talk about one
aspect of running your
applications in Kubernetes,
autoscaling.
As the popularity of
Kubernetes has grown,
the community isn't the
only thing that's scaled up.
You also need to think about how
your applications will scale.
Today, we'll look at autoscaling
your applications in GKE.
I'm Kaslin Fields, and I'm
a Developer Advocate here
at Google Cloud, where I focus
on Google Kubernetes Engine,
or GKE, as well as
open-source Kubernetes.
And today, we're going to take
a closer look at the autoscaling
capabilities of GKE.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
At some point, you've
probably been in a situation
where you've had to
think about bin packing.
Bin packing is the
concept of packing items
inside a confined space in
order to use the space most
efficiently.
The same concept applies when
you're running applications
on infrastructure.
You want to use your
infrastructure resources
you're paying for,
such as CPU and memory,
as efficiently as possible.
For example, here's a diagram
showing a Google Cloud N1
standard 16 compute instance
with 16 vCPUs and 64 gigs
of memory.
The boxes coming from the
bottom left of the graph
represent workloads.
You can see that around
12.5 vCPU of the 16 vCPU
and 28.5 gigabytes out
of the 64 gigabytes
are utilized by these workloads.
This means that there are about
3 vCPU and over 30 gigabytes
of RAM on this machine that
are not being utilized.
Running machines that use these
resources more efficiently
would help you to
optimize your cost,
but figuring out which workloads
will be run on which machines,
and thus managing the
utilization of your resources,
can be quite challenging.
Wouldn't it be easier
if the platform you're
running your application
on could simply
detect its required
resource utilization
and adjust accordingly?
This is the concept
behind autoscaling.
When using Google
Kubernetes Engine,
there are four
types, or dimensions,
of autoscaling that
you should consider--
Horizontal Pod Autoscaling, or
HPA, Vertical Pod Autoscaling,
or VPA, Cluster Autoscaler,
CA, and Node Auto Provisioner,
or NAP.
This diagram illustrates
these scalability dimensions.
On the top, you'll
see autoscalers
that relate to scaling your
workloads or Kubernetes pods.
On the bottom, you'll
see autoscalers
that relate to scaling your
infrastructure or nodes.
The horizontal pod autoscaler
and cluster autoscaler,
which are both on the
left of the diagram,
both deal with
increasing or decreasing
the number of something.
In the case of HPA,
that would mean
increasing the number of
pods running your workload
to meet demand, or
potentially decreasing
the number of pods running your
workload when demand is low.
The cluster autoscaler
can be configured
to increase the number of nodes
in your cluster to meet demand
or, conversely, to reduce the
number of nodes in your cluster
so you're using your resources
most efficiently during times
of low demand.
On the right side
of the diagram are
autoscalers which change
the size of something.
The Vertical Pod Autoscaler,
or VPA, on the top
can help you set the best
resource requests and limits
for the workloads you're
running in Kubernetes pods.
The node autoprovisioner
on the bottom
can select Compute
instance sizes
in order to most efficiently
pack your workloads based
on resource utilization.
Together, these four
dimensions of autoscaling
provide tools that enable you
to run both the infrastructure
of your workloads, as well
as the workloads themselves,
on your Google Kubernetes
Engine clusters efficiently,
with minimal configuration as
your clusters needs change.
It's also important to
mention that Google Kubernetes
Engine recently introduced
a new type of autoscaler
called the multidimensional
pod autoscaler.
As the name implies,
the new tool
combines the capabilities of
the horizontal and vertical pod
autoscalers in order
to provide a more
streamlined and
easier-to-use method
to optimize the efficiency of
your workloads running on GKE.
Your usage of these FOUR
autoscaling dimensions
will be a little
different depending
on whether you're using Google
Kubernetes Engine in a Standard
or Autopilot mode.
We dive deeper into the
differences between these modes
in GKE Essentials--
Cluster Modes.
Be sure to check out that
video for more details.
While these various
types of autoscalers
can save you time and cost,
configuring and understanding
all of the autoscalers is
still quite a bit to remember.
GKE Autopilot mode provides
a more hands-off approach
by configuring the
infrastructure components
of cluster autoscaling for you.
This means that when running
Autopilot mode GKE clusters,
you would want to
focus on configuring
any of the pod
autoscaling options,
and you would not need to worry
about the cluster autoscaler
dimensions.
These autoscaling tools can
help make your work easier
and more efficient.
They can also help you
optimize your costs
so that you're using the
resources you're paying for
most efficiently.
Here are some
additional resources
which you can find
in the description
below that can
help you learn more
about optimizing your costs
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
The four dimensions
of autoscaling
in Google Kubernetes Engine
play an important role
when configuring
your workloads to run
efficiently on Kubernetes.
With the concepts
discussed in this video,
we're confident
you'll be on your way
to building a GKE cluster
that suits your needs.
You can get started with GKE
by visiting the Google Cloud
Console and checking
out the links below.
And stay tuned for our next
videos, where we dive deeper
into GKE topics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]